thank you
[Music]
so there's a guy named Stephen
McCullough he's a gaming streamer on
Twitch
uh while he was broadcasting live from
his home his wife was stabbed to death
in another uh location Molly yeah while
he was streaming
this is why you can't be playing you
can't be playing video games all day
when your wife is out yeah
I'm true though
the crazy thing is that uh he's still
being arrested as the prime suspect what
oh damn so he for real he's actually a
[__] thinking murderer how do you
think that is so he he actually made the
twitch his Alibi he live streamed in
order to have it Alibi this is like
solid level Mastermind okay remember
that time we did a story about how a
dentist hired some black dude to shoot
his wife right and then he was like I
don't know why I'm getting arrested and
they found like he just texted him like
Hey kill my wife yeah yeah it's probably
the same [__] oh he wasn't clean he's on
Livestream like did it happen yet
kill my wife so uh investigators you
know like of course when any murder
happens and there's a spouse that's the
first person they always like look to
yeah
um and they investigated him and one of
the investigators which is I think is
pretty cool that this investigator is
able to like see it this way because
most you would think most cops like
don't know twitch or don't know all that
stuff
um but the detective figured out that it
was a recorded video on his live stream
whoa how do you figure that out I don't
know it's like I'm always watching ASMR
videos and I know when the girl's not
really [__] touching the mic or
whatever so you use it as an alibi to
say that he was there he was he was at
yeah so like like Ocean's Eleven yeah
what I'm doing to make it seem like it's
real right oh [__] [__] which is what
gave it all uh the Bellagio sign I don't
know if there's I don't know if there's
something that you can kind of look at
maybe within the um
the metadata or maybe yeah maybe
responding to anybody that was like in
his stream and he was talking about
something completely different that's
true yeah because if you can't respond
yeah that is true you wouldn't be able
to you wouldn't be able to type back so
he wasn't even really there he was
actually off stabbing his own life
oh my a piece of [__] dude
um I don't I think he's okay you want
you wanna you know why yeah now it's
because she kept she kept trying to tell
him stop playing games and he's like
well if I had to choose I guess I have
to choose my games oh God you ever heard
about people so addicted to the video
games I gotta choose my games is that
what you ever heard of people that's so
addicted to their games and [__] they
neglect the [__] out of their babies and
then they die I could hear that when I
played Call of Duty with random
strangers yeah yeah there's always a
baby crying the most popular thing like
let's say you just go into public he's
your [__] kid and you can hear
everybody he's like [__] going on in
their house and you can just hear babies
crying and like you just hear kids
yelling and like and it's funny to go
bro what do you go take care of your
kids tell them [__] loser [__] you
man
it's so funny uh talk [__] yeah it's all
yeah exactly it is how you talk [__] but
yeah it's it's also yeah you gotta do
your real Call of Duty you got kids
[__]
I mean Joe soundbite and this one is so
good
yeah oh dude this okay even to add more
like Macabre to this she was pregnant as
well oh [__] does he already have kids
though classic right
players
see this is the I'm telling you he
wanted to continue playing video games
and he realized that the kid's gonna
kill his game
I know it's in Northern Ireland oh [__]
Northern Ireland what's the difference
between if it's in Ireland or the states
are different they're funny you picture
McGregor playing games huh yeah 13 13
seconds
that's all I could say in Irish 13. all
I need is 13 seconds more it does 13
seconds more even in this recorded fake
live stream he's even he even recorded
himself like so he's playing Grand Theft
Auto whatever but then he's also saying
oh sorry guys there's a glitch and I
can't respond to the chat so he's like
he made a alibi as to why he's not
typing as well wow what the heck well
it's crazy it's like 2 p.m right now
when he's actually like playing at 2PM
he's holding up today's newspaper oh
this cop is [__] sharp yeah that's
what's cool it's like they don't
normally I feel like well because it's
an Irish cop
what does that mean
you know in the movies 13 seconds 30
seconds I'm gonna find him
so short
they do
yeah it's like Vietnamese people they do
the best nails
Irish people do the best copying oh you
policing against uh Chinese immigrants
you mean those ones like the guy with
the patellas yeah detective yeah and
he's got his thing in his [__] mouth
yeah and all the movies the cops are
Irish people these rolling is [__]
mustache see that's why they do their
job look at Liam Neeson he's Irish is
Irish I think he can take in right does
he have accent he is Irish though isn't
he he's just Irish I don't know if he's
I don't know
isn't he Irish in uh gangs from New York
yeah he's in gains in New York yeah he's
the dad in the very beginning before Leo
turns into a grown ass man wait Liam
Neeson's the dad yeah in the beginning
who dies at the hand of the butcher
spoiler alert
I didn't really know that Five Points
[__] fight and then
on the [__] like
[__] like that yeah
you're such a sick ass music me too I
like it I like it
for it to be remastered in 4k with
dolby's surround sound but other than
that it's pretty good Cameron Diaz was
an interesting casting choice too
I thought you said she was Irish I was
like no because it's so like so like
poppy mainstream and then let's like put
in a movie that's like Scorsese it's
like interesting she's a Charlie's Angel
she does good at that character though
she does good but just the interesting
she's also like that like you want to
save her but she's half evil [__] in her
hair you know what I'm talking about wow
yeah she had a little [__] in her like
like Pitch Perfect cast and Annapurna
They Don't Really Annapurna or like a24
they don't
mixed cast like guy and I mean like you
got that crowd and it's just the
interesting casting Choice yeah I don't
know I feel like she's always that role
even in [__] Any Given Sunday she's
like oh yeah likeable but like also half
[__] you know what I mean poppy
mainstream which is interesting
I think they should have used Dr Quinn
Medicine Woman oh she's great she's fine
too though but she looks of that era
what is her name but I I don't know I
remember things that was a kind of like
she was a woman when I was a kid so like
her personality was so soft it was like
so nurturing oh and then you see her in
[__] uh Wedding Crashers yeah and
you're like this girl's crazy it was
different she was amazing
yeah she's like the one seduce you yeah
she's like the Honeypot seductive milk
lady kitty cat
who's a great character I'm so glad they
chose her for that yeah that was so good
now that I think about it she's always
at role to me that's like I don't like
her but I like like her oh Jane Seymour
that's her name James is that what it is
tolerate tolerate but like that's that
character she plays though it's not just
like a feeling that you have about her
as like an actress it's like that's her
character every single time
she's a little bit Charming
no yeah yeah
was like no dude okay gets away with
things that like normally a regular
human being should not be getting away
with that kind of [__] all the time it's
a movie it is a movie and she's hella
fine at least we know now that like I'm
glad that this happened because no not
that it happened but I'm glad that uh
they were able to catch catch a
[__] because I feel like some
people would think that's an easy Alibi
to have to be life in some way yeah and
uh yeah I'm surprised it didn't happen
sooner but
um I'm sorry what I was gonna say was on
Twitch like there's a difference when
you like upload a video versus when you
like like screaming right like on your
library of of uh yeah I mean it depends
because I know like if you're running on
like an OBS or something like it's it's
it could be hard to tell like it's like
you're like versus the camera showing
you it's more like you have a feed of
something else
so maybe it wasn't so much like that
there's like a a technical notation as
it is the investigator was just like
this is bad acting oh I see you know
maybe and then looked into it further I
don't know because it doesn't say like
how he actually did it but like if the
dude is playing this role of like oh
here I am at home uh streaming I'm
definitely not anywhere else yeah I'm
definitely not killing my wife right
just cracking jokes like that but also
too with a murder he probably wasn't
very clean in how he like exactly like
he would have to be yeah he's probably a
better streamer than he is a murderer
yeah he's probably a terrible murderer
first time plus um what is it like uh
somebody correct me if they they
understand this but like when you uh
were to murder a pregnant woman uh is it
based off is that like double double
homicide well yeah it's double right
there based off of like a trimester
thing too like has that been like an
argument before you know what I'm saying
I don't I you know what I think it's
based off I think it's based off
awareness
I think like if you I think like you
knew that it's more premedited that you
killed two people I think there's it
changes the degree right because because
the same way that like how he how he
planned this it's like first degree yeah
right so it's a more severe sentence
yeah so maybe yeah I'm sure like your
chances of not getting charged for the
baby are pretty freaking low how far
along was she question it's like halfway
out no way I can imagine
she's giving birth
oh yeah no I don't know how far along
she was but man why did she have to nag
so hard okay I know
could have saved her lives when are you
gonna learn women
play just let the guy game you know play
[__] Grand Theft Auto I like at the
beginning that's why you don't play
games all day when your woman's out the
house
he wasn't around to protect her when a
crazy homeless guy stabbed her up
[Music]